we have a voicemail number its 2192 david p here's a real quick voicemail that you may find interesting take a listen yes my man David mr. pike man you gorgeous little rascal you that's what are you married I thought I heard you say she had children more little girl but um that's something you deserve because you are good man this is old crazy hypocritical he loves Oh hits from Bossier shreveport-bossier louisiana la banana republic of the style alright let's cut it there we uh yeah I i I'm not married I've never said that I have kids and uh that's that glad to get an opportunity to clear that up & bossier city sounds like an interesting place I would be very interested in seeing what exactly goes on down there we've got a great bonus show today I don't even have time to tell you about it but you can sign up and get access to it at david pakman.com slash membership